here to talk about the employment report
the economy and why so many jobs are
going unfilled is cbs news senior
business analyst
jill schlesinger jill uh good morning
the economy does seem to be getting
better but maybe not as quickly as
people hoped why this big miss
well i mean in this report as we just
heard there is a bit of a timing issue
the survey period is in the first two
weeks of september that is when the
delta variant was really raging so
that's one aspect one other part is
there is a little quirk in this report
in that we saw a lot of job losses in
public sector education now that could
be just a timing issue of when teachers
were rehired to start school again
finally those labor shortages are real
mostly for lower paying jobs remember
these reports they get subject to
revision for the two next months so we
could see jobs actually trend higher
than originally reported that's what
happened in the previous month we are
actually averaging
561 000 jobs a month this year so it's
good it's not a million it is not zero
and we are making progress
jill the unemployment rate dropped to
4.8 percent that that's the lowest it's
been since the
pandemic started so like we would think
that's good news but that's
a huge
big monthly drop
what's behind it
so the unemployment rate is determined
by whether you have a job or you're
actively looking for a job so the drop
is partially positive and negative news
the positive news tens of thousands of
people they got jobs great but the
negative part is that we saw about 186
000 people leave the labor force now why
did they do that maybe they have child
care issues maybe they're worried about
covid maybe they just don't have the
transportation to get to the job or they
can't move to where the job is overall
at 4.8 percent i think it's an important
barrier to break down below the 5 number
but we do want to get there for the good
reason that lots of people flow into the
labor force because they seek
opportunities and those opportunities
are available for them
jill i think the quote from the
president was jobs up wages up
unemployment down we've hit two of them
let's go to wages wages are up
yeah this is really good news so wages
year over year so we have annual wage
increases of 4.6
now this is incredibly important because
as we know the price of everything is
rising we are contending with inflation
so one of the aspects of the shrinking
labor force is that wages have to rise
to get people to come work now the thing
that's important and what we need to
keep an eye on is that those wages rise
faster than prices right now it's a
little bit the wrong direction wages are
not rising quite as fast as the overall
inflation rate the fed is betting that
that
that scenario will flip in the future
all right jill schlesinger as always
great information thank you